welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and the live-action spider-verse
has gone from an open-ended grape
flavored window of opportunity after
spider-man no we home to a befuddling
blood-flavored punch of the mouth after
morbius's post-credit scenes morby
spoilers ahead but somehow the logic of
no way home was distorted so that mcu
characters can now be randomly
transported in a one-way trip into a
separate universe leaving them with
unexplained hostility for spider-man how
did this happen what went wrong well the
director of the morbius film daniel
espinoza who i gotta say is a talented
filmmaker who does not deserve the blame
for sony's multiverse meddling here this
guy has bravely opened up about these
creative choices allowing us to diagnose
where things might have gone awry and
how sony can really easily fix this
broken universe morbius was originally
scheduled to release in july 2020 in its
first trailer you may remember released
in january 2020 a trailer that
referenced spider-man in the form of
some graffiti in the inclusion of
michael keaton as adrian toombs vulture
of spider-man homecoming a story set in
the marvel cinematic universe this
morbius film was intended to release
after spider-man far from home and after
sony's renegotiation of their spider-man
deal with disney and marvel studios for
a third film which was supposed to come
out in july 2021 morbius was also
supposed to release long before the
venom sequel venom let there be carnage
and it's crazy post-credit scene in an
interview with insider espinoza said
that vulture was never intended to be
part of the film's main story but that
the idea to feature michael keaton came
up before they shot the film all part of
an agenda to show off the spider-verse i
think what many of us now forget because
it happened in the before times is that
at the time of that january 2020 trailer
for morbius the biggest marvel title in
recent memory was spider-man far from
home which ended with the post-credits
scene that brought back jk simmons and j
jonah jameson a cross-universe cameo
that also doesn't make a whole lot of
logical sense when you think about it
but the fans still loved it nonetheless
and just assumed that jk simmons could
play the same character in different
universes and sony from that likely
assumed that we would all have the same
thrilled reaction to michael keaton
probably a mistake leaning on keaton so
heavily for the marketing giving fans a
false impression of what this movie
would be instead of leaving keaton as a
surprise for which our appreciation
would outshine our overthinking but at
any rate the pandemic shut everything
down in march 2020 and morbius got
delayed first to march 2021 then to
october 2021 then to january 2022 and
then finally to april 2022 and in the
midst of all this sony who is always
under pressure to release new spider-man
films about every two years to retain
their film rights to the character
shuffled up the schedule so that
spider-man no way home would come out in
december 2021 before morbius so espinoza
said that it was hard to see morbius a
movie shot from february 2019 and
wrapped by june 2019 meaning they
started shooting this before end game
came out it was hard for him to see this
movie mostly locked now coming out in a
world after superhero movie expectations
completely shifted so it sounds like
michael keaton was intended to be a
post-credits scene cameo who meets
morbius which is why in earlier trailers
the two crossed paths you and i should
stay in touch
but after the movie got delayed to its
final april 2022 release date a decision
that was made in early january after no
way home came out trailers that were
released after that downplayed tomb's
interaction with morbius and instead
showed new footage of him alone in his
prison cell suggesting that much of this
was completely reconfigured after no way
home came out and in an interview with
uproxx espinosa confirmed that the
release of spider-man no way home
totally changed how sony wanted tomb's
arrival to look like in the morbius film
he said when spider-man nomihum came out
sony said this is how the visual effects
are and then the idea of having him just
encountering him in that universe seemed
too complicated and then we put it in
the end we have to match i don't know
how the transportation would look like
in that there were all these small
things that had to be addressed but i
think that the concept of having
different timelines were i believe came
from sony not from kevin feige it was
sony that initiated that idea so in
other words espinoza wanted to just have
morbius casually encounter tombs similar
to how peter parker casually sees j.k
simmons as shiron jameson as someone
already existing in that universe but
then after no way home sony insisted
that this scene use the same purple sky
cracks and the same white glowing
teleporting as the multiverse crossovers
in no way home problem is by doing that
sony really anchored morbius to the no
way home multiverse logic despite
honestly none of us fully understanding
that movie's logic still fans walked out
of it in the weeks after that movie
inferring enough logic that we needed to
process the movie but clearly sony did
not understand their own movie's
implications and by trying to use that
complicated logic to explain something
that didn't need an explanation they
ultimately implied adrian toombs
permanently left the mcu and entered a
universe where he has no resources and
no relationship with spider-man making
it completely nonsensical that he would
have his same vulture wings once more
and have any feelings whatsoever towards
this universe's spider-man still there
is a silver lining folks and that is
that this universe that tombs has just
joined still has a chance to be a really
awesome universe the director confirmed
that the universe morbius and tombs are
now in is the same universe as venom and
carnage and there is every reason to
believe that from sony's perspective
this is the same universe as the one
that they left off with in 2014's the
amazing spider-man 2 with andrew
garfield as peter parker in the early
makings of the sinister six because in
every interview espinoza confirms that
there is a spider-man but he jokes that
sony would shoot him if he says anything
said sony
seriously we will and since espinoza is
totally okay speculating that the
animated miles morales could make his
way into live-action it just sounds to
me that his taboo words are andrew and
garfield espinoza even went as far as to
say in all the different marvel
timelines you have a spider-man it's a
totem in the marvel universe what you
say is that you have to have a
spider-man in each universe for it to
function he's one of the fundamental
beings he's totally right spider-man is
truly the focal character of the
multiverse in marvel lore the axis
character upon which it all hinges when
a new universe is presented it's usually
one centered around a new spider-man
variant so i think sony really is an
opportunity to redefine toombs's
transference from the mcu to the
venomverse as a random mistake
redefining it as a crucial plot point a
side effect of andrew garfield's return
to his home reality at the end of that
film how as a totem fundamental being
his arachno frequency towed in his wake
one character resistant to the memory
wipe affecting the rest of the mcu
through the nebulous space between
realities that also includes craven
rhino scorpion black hat madame webb all
the rest all of these characters now
respawning in the venomverse alongside
andrew and tombs a universe where peter
parker is the center of it and madame
webb defines this multiverse as a
spider-centric web of life and destiny
and that everything confusing about
those purple cracks was really according
to her and her webb's design because how
good is a vulture in a cage having no
memory of his captor free the bird and
give the fatherless peter a papa i mean
i don't know i feel like dakota johnson
can say something cooler than that
that's just that's just my pitch i mean
sony could just claim this as a win and
say this universe was always andrew
garfield's universe and now this
universe is centered around the peter
parker with the best character arc and
one of the biggest films of all time a
broken peter who began his story bitter
and rageville but ends with his
amazingness affirmed andrew garfield
worked so well in no way home because
the story embraced the mistakes his era
of the character was most criticized for
and sony can now do the same thing with
tombs and morbius and since espinosa is
betting our lives that sony plans to
bring into the spider-verse miles
morales into live-action and it was
andrew in lecture who speculated about
the black spider-man in that scene i
think we all agree that this peter works
best as an older brother and could be an
amazing mentor to miles morales ah this
is so cool
i always wanted brothers let me know
your thoughts on all this in the
comments below follow me on instagram
and twitter at eight boss following
rockstar subscribe to interaction for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you